[Music]
welcome to the AI in the future of us a
podcast Style video series that explodes
the ways AI is shaping our feature and
how we can prepare for the changes that
Leia has I'm your host Ferra seconder
and today we are joined by some mcviti
who is the area Tech lead for data
analytics here in Google Cloud thank you
for being here today Sam my pleasure
thank you so much for inviting let's
start with some backgrounds and you know
I know that you have done a lot of
things in you know Google and data
analytics and AI space and you know
could you please tell us a bit about
your background and expertise in the
field of data and analytics and AI
yeah definitely so I I sort of grew up
doing streaming analytics that is the
first team that I joined and and since
then it really expanded my horizons to
work on a bunch of different projects
throughout data analytics and then as as
AI has become increasingly important
both deep and my own understanding you
know it's fun to read a lot of papers as
well as working with colleagues who are
you know have them doing that for years
and years so it's a really exciting time
to be part of the sort of convergence of
these two areas and and really looking
to see what we can do
yes it's interesting right and we are
saying the two very distinct areas are
really coming together as well these
days and I still agree with you uh could
you share some of the key AI
developments that you have witnessed
during your you know career as well
please sure so I mean I think the the
one that we're all very familiar with is
self-driving cars and I think that one
is is really interesting because it's
sort of you know full self-driving cars
are always five years away and you're
asking five years and they're five years
away and and I think that that's really
instructive because I think one of the
really interesting and terrifying things
about AI is is we don't know where the
asymptotes are like are we are we
hitting diminishing returns now
or not and and you sort of find that out
with each new application so there's
that one I mean as somebody who played a
bunch of Starcraft as a kid I was very
excited to see the alpha star stuff that
deepmind did that was that was pretty
impressive so those are maybe the two
that I would highlight
yes and I think we all played Warcraft
and you know it's interesting where
things are leading to right from the
times that you know we dealt with all of
that as well so uh and let's look at a
little bit of the impact or AI on data
analytics ecosystem and I know that you
are really passionate about this and you
have been really you know one of the
leading folks here as well so with the
use of the Gen AI applications such as
Bart now ai is top of mind for everyone
you know and I I I don't spend a day
actually these days that goes by without
talking to a customer around Janai as
well and in your opinion what are the
most significant ways that AI is
currently impacting the society as well
yeah such a big question I I think it's
really shining a light on what what does
knowledge actually mean and what does
understanding mean and and sort of where
is there a difference between those and
so I think you you see sort of those
lines blur but you see things that you
know large language models are really
good at as far as summarization
translation things like that but then
sort of deductive reasoning is still
more of an open problem and so I think
that often we sort of put those all in
the same bucket but this is really
teaching us how they're they're
different and they're different problems
and so that's that's been really
interesting
and
I you know I think we'll we'll see as
new models emerge what capabilities they
have but it's it's sort of trying to to
walk that line of there are some things
that they're really good at and how to
explore those capabilities while also
being aware that there's some things
that maybe they a little overconfident
about and and how do you you manage that
it's and it's interesting right that
despite all the knowledge and expertise
we are still learning which is a great
thing about this how these are
interacting with all the new use cases
that are coming through as well and
Technology custom is expanding pretty
rapidly because of that and generative
AI is acting as a catalyst and you know
everyone is interested in this how do
you see AI evolving in the you know data
analytics ecosystem in the next few
years and what impact do you think that
you know it will have on number of
Industries out there as well
so my my hope is that it really becomes
a tool for sort of democratization and
accessibility I think that as someone
who has that a fair amount of time
learning different programming languages
and things like that I recognize that
those those can be a huge barrier for
folks and so I think that there's
there's a really exciting trend of
actually treating natural language like
an interface to a bunch of different
surfaces that you couldn't before and so
I think that that I hope has the
potential to really change who gets to
do data analytics and how much time they
have to put in to be able to be at that
table so I think that that part is
really exciting for me
I think the the sort of flip side of
that is that
for for folks that have worked in data
they know that you can you can tell
misleading stories with data as well and
so I do worry a bit that it's going to
make it easier to just sort of spend
misleading things
with with data tools and so I think we
have to figure out how to to really like
build guardrails around that where we
can
and I think you're absolutely right that
you know I write Secrets still better
than you know writing SQL code and I'm
looking forward to using you know these
tools and that they've been helping me
you know from the SQL side but I also I
agree that you know data is effectively
what you make out of it right and how
much that you use for depending on the
problem that you are as well and you are
I think as Photon that we need to make
sure the rail gets around that and what
are the examples of how generous
currently being effectively used in the
data analytics and business intelligence
ecosystem as well from your point of
view
so right now I think where we're seeing
people do some very very successful
experiments around sort of basic natural
language to SQL and other
other languages I think one of the the
really nice sort of things that it's
proven to be good at is also translating
to different charting libraries and so
you can say like make me a graph and
the current models are pretty good at
that and I think that that's one of
these examples of hopefully that
actually allows people to convey
information better and makes it more
accessible than it was before instead of
you know step one like buy the charting
Library like step two learn how it works
step three debug and like step four show
the graph like that hopefully that all
just gets Tighter and and more
accessible
it is definitely going to make us a lot
more productive right because
particularly folks who are you know
capable and understanding and have the
foundations of doing this rather than
you going and shopping around and
looking for different things how they
work it will it will accelerate and you
know act as a catalyst for the
professionals as well I think uh and
with that what while you does gen AI
bring to organizations
so I I hope that it brings sort of a lot
more optionality and flexibility in
terms of what technologies that
organizations can adapt and how they can
change their plans where I I sort of
informally like to refer to generative
AI is as super glue in a lot of cases
because I think a lot of the things that
hold organizations back from adopting a
new technology is that you've got you
know 10 years of accumulated glue code
that works with the old technology and
nobody knows how it works and nobody
wants to rewrite it and and I think that
you know with the translation
capabilities and generative AI you you
really are able to say like
no let's use this new library and like
let's you know we have an AI to do some
of that translation that is just
otherwise just intractively large
and so I hope that it allows sort of new
technologies to emerge and be adopted in
a way that was just harder before
because that barrier to entry was was so
so high
yes and coming from the you know they
can't expect ground I I can relate to
that right because one of the challenges
that I always faced you always find a
Mainframe somewhere that there's the
Cobble that you really need to look into
it it is it is a you know and you know I
I never understood how it works actually
despite it is you know the way that it
is very C like as well at some point so
but and there are also challenges right
and you know an uplying and using
generative AI as well and what are the
main overlaps that you see because we
treated business intelligent data
analytics and machine learning as
separate entities in many organizations
this is what we see from most of our
customers as well as well at the moment
right and and how do you think that this
will play out
so I I think there's a sort of a really
exciting like closing the loop aspect to
what's happening right now because
because I think that it was sort of an
Open Secret that maybe 80 of doing ml
before is actually like Gathering data
and creating the data and understanding
your data and then 20 to this is during
the actual model mechanics and training
and things like that and so I think it's
been the case that sort of data has
always fed machine learning and and now
we're in this really exciting place
where like machine learning can
potentially augment how you are
interacting with data so it can help you
do data cleaning it can help with all
these analytics and charting tasks that
we talked about before so I think like
it's it's really exciting that that
becomes sort of a two-way street and
that there's sort of a lot more
collaboration opportunities opened up by
it
yes and I totally agree and I can relate
to that right and my background is ML
and you know but I no one wants to pay
my skills at you know 20 years ago when
I was doing this and I spent most of my
time in data I became so good at it so I
moved disciplines as a result of it as
well right so and it is you are
absolutely right it is still the case
that the data preparation is core and
then you know bigger part of the ml as
well but with that uh my next the next
thing that comes to my mind is you know
what are the most pressing ethical
considerations surrounding AI
development the news with the data
analytics in mind for you
yeah that that's another big big
question I mean I think that I would I
would make sure that that folks are are
referring to the scholarship of folks
like Sophia Noble and Virginia Eubanks
and all the folks that have looked at
sort of what does it mean to ethically
use algorithms or or decide that
ethically you shouldn't use a given
algorithm and so I think that that sort
of trend certainly emerges here is where
we look at Ai and we say rather than
assume that it is perfectable to to
really look critically at use cases and
say
is this is this purpose fit for this you
know do the the benefits outweigh the
harms and maybe yes maybe no but to
really leave that question open because
I like
I think that as a society we really like
to sort of break to break problems down
into like how can we fix this with
technology
and and sometimes technology is great
and and other times it really like
requires nuance and subtlety that is
just really really hard to to reach with
the given technology and you know you
can perpetuate a lot of harms if you
sort of ignore those nuances
so I think they're very concretely
and in a lot of the models today like we
recognize that there's there's bias
training data that's going into them and
I think the sort of state of the art is
to to basically teach models to to sort
of self-censor at The Last Mile and say
like oh don't say that thing that's the
bad thing but but in the data ecosystem
what really concerns me is that if those
biases are still retained in the model
and we're asking people to do sort of
complex analyzes and look at
correlations and different things I
think there are ways that sort of really
sort of negative harmful correlations
could appear in analytics in a way that
is not obvious to those sort of low-pass
filters that say like are you saying
something blatantly offensive and so I
think especially when we're looking at
things like demographic data wouldn't be
really really careful on understanding
what what correlations might be hidden
in the data that correspond to you know
bias's training set so that's that's
what keeps me up at night
yes and it the key is I think that you
to have the human Centric Approach at
the end of the day and you know sorted
as much as we can with the data because
the ml algorithms are biased with the
data that we are feeding to it
effectively and then that biases you
know propagated through the algorithms
as well at the end of the day and I
think you are absolutely right that is
the one of the key things as well but
I'd like to look ahead a little bit and
let's look into how the AI and business
intelligence you know comes across as
well what do you believe the most
exciting potential because it is giving
a lot of opportunities to us o AI that
we have yet to see with the you know
data analytics tools
yeah so maybe a couple of things I think
one one is just the the idea that we
could use natural language as an
interface to all these things that we
couldn't before I think that just is
like fundamentally such an empowering
idea if we can do that thoughtfully that
like that that's just really exciting
and then I think along those same lines
I I sort of think about like what are
what are all the expensive things that
we're used to doing that all of a sudden
get much easier and then how does that
mean that we could actually rethink
these workflows in a fundamentally new
way so you know you usually we have this
assumption that like it takes a lot of
time to write SQL because I have to
think about the question I want to ask
and the translated SQL and debug and if
that if that sort of distance or that
that time investment becomes very small
like what does that mean about my
ability to iterate on different
questions or to to spend that time
Elsewhere on different pieces of the
system so I think we have sort of all
these built-in assumptions to how we've
built things over time and this gives us
a chance to revisit those and maybe
build fundamentally new experiences
and uh and I agree with you and this is
the opportunity course right because if
we spend time on the things that we can
improve and save time on we can focus on
the things that will add more value to
the things that we are working on as
well and and with that what what advice
would you give to individuals working in
data analytics looking to explore the
the feature that AI is clearly going to
play a lot more significant role
yeah I think broadly it's sort of
prepare for the unexpected but I think
there's there's ways to sort of
thoughtfully do that is that you can
sort of look at like different different
branches the future might take and so
you know one of them is
we've sort of seen a big burst of
generative AI accomplishments and the
sort of pieces are on the table and
we're going to spend the next six 12
months figuring out how to assemble
those another possible future is we
continue to sort of see accelerating
advancements and you know a bunch of the
things that we thought were true are no
longer true in three months and so you
just sort of weighing those and acting
accordingly
sorry one one concrete thing that I
think is important just is just sort of
to potentially not over index on any
single approach because it might
actually turn out to be obsolete in
three months and so the the one that I'm
most most favorite of uh talking about
is
when folks do prompt engineering it's
it's really really easy to sort of get
carried away there and and sort of spend
hours and hours crafting perfect prompt
and then the model comes out and your
prompt no longer works and and so I
think just figuring out how to to sort
of apply each approach in moderation and
apply a variety of approaches so you can
you can sort of hedge and say you know
where might this be hitting diminishing
returns where should I try a different
strategy and so as a as a data person I
think like figuring out those different
strategies and and just also building a
good mental model for what models can
and can't do I think there are there are
sort of hats that they're really good at
of like the translator the summarizer
and so if you think about those you can
start to Intuit different system
diagrams that puts those in those
different roles and takes advantage of
their capabilities and I think that's a
lot more helpful than just sort of
treating it as like this generic magic
box that that does you know some things
but other things not well and so I think
trying to sort of systematize it and
taxonomize
what what this might be for different
data workflows is a couple things that I
would I would suggest
and and I agree and I recently read that
you know it wasn't hard at business for
you around the future engineering
actually this is one of the things that
they discuss in detail that that you are
spending lots of time on tuning your
problems but as you say the model is
changing and then models will get better
and better to accommodate more generic
and more the spoken language as well as
you say with the nature language so it
is important to understand the
fundamentals of how all of this works as
well and as the English you know Old
English saying goes horses for courses
where you should be using the right
tools as well in a sense I think would
be the key and as we look ahead to the
future of AI and this is my last
question what do you believe are the
most critical areas of research and
development that need to be addressed to
make it more effective
so I mean I I think that I I sort of
gravitate immediately toward the
guardrails because I think sort of
naturally people are going to want to
build more and more powerful models and
like that that part is is you know gonna
take care of itself For Better or For
Worse but I think that in terms of you
know teaching models humility is is one
thing that I you know would love to to
see sort of that that formalized more
where we sort of have these rough ideas
of confidence scores but you know I
think especially with some of the early
chat models that just saw like this the
sort of unearned confidence of I'm going
to tell you this thing which is
flagrantly not true but I'm going to say
it in a very convincing confident way
you know I think it could be really
powerful if we actually sort of were
able to incorporate human Notions of
humility and that sort of idea of I
might not have all the answers here
here's my best guess and and presenting
that in a more nuanced sort of qualified
way
and then you know certainly responsible
AI I I think that you know some of the
some of the ideas in synthetic data
generation and how you could potentially
re-weight a training set to say
this this has these biases let's let's
fix those in the training set before we
train the model I think those are
there's some really exciting important
areas
and then looking at that sort of
societal implications I think the the
work that's happening in water marketing
AI generated content is incredibly
important I think that they're just
they're sort of going to be this this
explosion of content and figuring out
how to to make sure that that is labeled
appropriately and understood
appropriately
is really important for how our society
sort of consumes and interacts with
information and interacts with each
other
and and I think that's that my point
that you made that is really important
right because the danger is that we
might end up with all the content
generated by machines at the end of the
day which which is the big danger here
and also it is you know it comes back
into the having this human-centric
Approach at the end of the day right so
what is right for you know doing it what
would be the right thing that you know
for the society I think is the key and
and things uh some I really appreciate
that you're joining us today it has been
incredible insightful you know to hear
your thoughts on the impact and
effective use of AI we look forward to
seeing how AI will continue to shape the
world around us and hope everyone has
been inspired with Embrace with the
potential opportunities thank you very
much indeed thank you so much my
pleasure foreign
[Music]